[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american fantasy adventure
comedy film called gulliver's travels
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
a middle-aged man named lemuel gulliver
wakes up in his messy new york apartment
and goes on with his morning routine he
talks to his superhero toys on a shelf
and dances in the shower showing us his
goofy side
gulliver works in the mail room of a new
york newspaper company that day he meets
a new employee named dan and befriends
him gulliver is dan's boss in the
mailing department
as the two deliver their mail for the
day they come across gulliver's longtime
crush and a journalist named darcy
silverman he has been in love with her
for years but has never confessed
later that day dan brings out a notice
that says he has been promoted to head
of the mail department on his first day
gulliver has been working in the
facility for 10 years but no one there
respects him
dan claims that gulliver is scared to
talk and will never progress in life
other than his mail room job
a distressed gulliver is walking out of
the office and notices darcy working
late he gathers up courage and goes to
her cabin to ask her out however his
nerves get the best of him so instead he
picks up a random paper from her desk
and heads out darcy asks him if he wants
to apply for a travel writing assignment
a nervous gulliver agrees and has to
submit a travel blog the following day
at home he copies and pastes several
articles from the internet for the blog
the following day at work he submits it
to darcy who is impressed by his writing
skills and provides him with a new task
she wants him to travel to the bermuda
triangle and write an article about the
legends of ships mysteriously
disappearing there to impress her
gulliver agrees darcy arranges a contact
and a boat for him
gulliver flies to bermuda the very next
day where he is picked up by a man he
takes gulliver to a rented boat and
shows him how to use it the journey is
pretty simple as the boat is automated
gulliver finally sails for the bermuda
triangle alone in the boat for the first
few hours he enjoys himself by reading
how to build a robot magazines and
drinking several cans of coke he soon
falls asleep
sometime later he wakes up to a massive
wave in front of him a sea storm hits
and he quickly puts a life jacket on the
boat shakes vigorously in the water
gulliver turns around to see an enormous
sea tornado coming his way gulliver with
his boat is sucked on top of the tornado
then right into its eye
the screen goes black
when gulliver opens his eyes he cannot
move his body he looks down and is
surprised when he sees some tiny men
standing on top of his chest their
leader introduces himself as the
commander edward edwardian of the lilly
putt the camera zooms out showing us a
crowd of tiny people standing around
gulliver he is pinned to the ground with
tiny ropes and wood commander edward
calls gulliver a beast a confused
gulliver yells in fear and breaks free
from the ropes easily thinking that this
is a dream he tries closing his eyes
edward orders his soldiers to bring the
beast down the soldiers attach their
hooks to gulliver's pants and make him
fall unconscious when he wakes up
gulliver finds himself tied to a cart
and being pulled into the kingdom of
lilliput the tiny civilians come out of
their houses to get a look at the beast
he is pulled into the royal palace and
presented to the king of lillyput king
theodore the king's daughter princess
mary pities gulliver and asks edward if
the restraints are necessary edward
claims that gulliver is a spy from their
enemy kingdom blephucia gulliver finally
speaks and asks the king where he is
king theodore's secretary jinx tells him
that he is in lilliput the greatest
nation in the world
gulliver thinks this is a prank and asks
the non-existent cameraman to show
himself
in the following scene we see gulliver
imprisoned inside a cave he meets a
fellow prisoner named horatio who was
sentenced to life by edward for trying
to court princess mary the two are
approached by edward again who listens
to them referring to him as lame ass
when an angry edward threatens to
imprison them for life gulliver claims
lame ass means someone who is brave
happy with the answer edward takes both
the prisoners to a field to plow it with
the help of gulliver's strength he
restrains gulliver with a machine just
then two rings of a bell are heard from
the palace indicating that blefucha has
attacked they are trying to kidnap
princess mary and have started a fire at
the palace edward quickly runs to the
palace and orders everyone not to save
the princess as he wants to be the one
to save her but horatio asks gulliver to
do it because edward can't reach her on
time gulliver easily takes the
blephesian soldiers down and saves the
princess but the king and his secretary
are stuck in the fire
gulliver in a hurry urinates on the
building everyone claps for him when he
stops the fire and saves king theodore
the king removes him and horatio from
imprisonment and thanks gulliver for his
bravery he also invites everyone for a
feast at night to celebrate the occasion
edward is furious to see someone else
being praised for their bravery at the
feast the king asks gulliver where he is
from and he answers he is from manhattan
the people assume that gulliver was the
president of manhattan as he is the
bravest one there gulliver feels like a
hero for the first time in his life so
he fabricates the story claiming he was
known as president of the awesome
everyone believes him except for edward
the following day the people of lillyput
build a massive home for gulliver with
all the facilities he couldn't get when
he was in new york gulliver also makes
them build a theater to fit everyone in
the kingdom then he shows them a drama
of the sinking titanic claiming it to be
the story of his life everyone is amazed
by the tragic life that he has had
edward inquires how he was saved after
drowning and gulliver claims that he was
resuscitated later horatio asks gulliver
to help him impress princess mary and
gulliver agrees the two go to the palace
and horatio approaches the princess a
hidden gulliver recites the lyrics of
the song kiss making horatio repeat it
by the end of it the princess starts to
fall for horatio but she is called by
edward who has come to court her the two
have been destined to get married as
edward is the bravest of the kingdom
princess mary isn't fond of edward but
she cannot seem to get rid of him
somewhere else the search party finds
the washed-up boat with cans of coke
gulliver comes to the scene and finds
his phone is still working he has 12
voice messages from darcy turns out she
is furious to have found out about
gulliver's plagiarized article
she has to now sail on the same trail
gulliver came through to do the bermuda
triangle research herself gulliver now
doesn't want to go back to new york and
face her so he decides to stay in
lillypot permanently edward is not happy
about the decision and tells the king he
is suspicious of gulliver the king
dismisses him claiming that he trusts
gulliver because of his stay the king
gives gulliver the title of the new
general and demotes edward to vice
general a jealous edward turns lily
putt's defense system off making it
easier for their enemies blaffucha to
attack blephusian's soldiers and their
king see this and plan to attack
lillyput immediately they approach the
kingdom through waters and launch
cannonballs towards lillyput being the
general now it is gulliver's
responsibility to stop them he nervously
steps into the water and starts to
splash it around the cannonballs do not
work on gulliver who is massive compared
to them eventually he defeats the
blephusians and becomes the savior of
lilliput the people from lillyput
fulfill all of gulliver's wishes they
even build a model of times square so he
would feel at home they changed their
clothing to match that of gulliver's
soldiers are appointed to cut his hair
and give him massages
one night edward barges into the
princess's chamber he claims that it is
his right to come in anytime because he
courts the princess the princess finally
reveals that she doesn't love him and
doesn't want him to court her anymore
an angered edward leaves for blephicia
to ask for help from their king edward's
men have found the build your robot book
gulliver had on the boat the blephusian
king agrees to help him build a robot
using the book to battle gulliver some
days later gulliver is at the model
times square when the bells of the
palace ring suggesting an invasion
gulliver gets ready to battle tiny
people but is surprised when a huge
robot being operated by edward stands in
front of him edward challenges him for a
duel gulliver has no way out but to
accept he tries to push the robot but it
is way stronger than him it picks
gulliver up with his pants and makes him
accept defeat gulliver also confesses
that everything he said about him being
the president is a lie the king and the
princess are surprised to have been
betrayed by him edward sends gulliver to
a forbidden place called the island
where we dare not go as a punishment
when gulliver is left there he is picked
up by a giant little girl turns out the
island is the home of giants the girl
thinks gulliver is a toy and keeps him
in her barbie house dressing him in
girly pink clothes
meanwhile back in lillyput darcy's body
washes up on the shore gulliver has told
everyone that darcy is his princess back
home so edward recognizes her and
imprisons her she meets king theodore
and his queen in the prison who have
been captured after gulliver's defeat
horatio sees this and decides to travel
to the island where we dare not go to
get gulliver back he is minuscule on the
island and manages to reach gulliver
safely the little girl's doll house also
has a skeleton of a dead us air force
pilot gulliver uses the parachute to
escape and fly back to lillyput he first
goes to meet darcy in the prison and
confesses that he has a crush on her she
forgives him for plagiarizing the
article and seems to be opening up to
him gulliver has decided to challenge
edward for a duel he doesn't want to
prove his bravery anymore but genuinely
wants to help lillyput the following day
the two stand before each other ready to
battle gulliver wants edward to give the
kingdom back to king theodore if he wins
but if he loses edward will destroy the
kingdom altogether the two fight and
edward overpowers him within seconds
horatio runs to help him and manages to
get inside the robot he defeats edward
from inside eventually de-powering the
robot after that gulliver easily manages
to defeat it and the crowd erupts in
cheers even darcy celebrates the win
because of horatio's bravery he has
provided permission to court princess
mary the two finally kiss
but just then edward who has reached the
point of insanity takes the princess
hostage but the princess finally having
enough of edward beats the traitor up in
frustration darcy then kisses gulliver
for the first time the blefutian king
and theodore are about to initiate the
war again but gulliver stops them he
successfully helps to make peace between
the rival island nations by reciting
edwin's star's war and finally he along
with darcy return to new york city on
their repaired ship
cut to a few weeks later gulliver has
left the mail room job and is a travel
writer now he and darcy are in a happy
relationship gulliver has just completed
a travel assignment and the movie ends
as the two walk out of darcy's office
while holding hands
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching